okay are you all ready for the last Talk
of the day
I know it sounds like oh my God I don't
want to be here anymore but it's just
like yes it's been a full-on day and
we're all ready for some beer right
yeah okay so
um
we're all here to basically learn about
playwrights I'm gonna ask a few
questions in a minute but um let's just
uh first of all
um I'll just do some introductions first
my name is Debbie O'Brien I'm a senior
program manager at Microsoft and I
basically I'm advocating for playwright
so my job is to make sure the community
of playwright grows that we have content
videos everything that you need in order
to learn playwright and be successful in
testings that's my job easy job right
yes I'm an international speaker I've
spoken in many places including
Antarctica which is my claim to fame
that was an amazing conference on a
cruise ship in Antarctica I'm a teacher
open source contributor playwright is
open source uh so you can all contribute
to that as well and um you'll normally
see me if you follow me on Twitter at
dubs underscore Brian you'll see me like
literally running cycling and doing
sport all over the place there's me
running in Oslo the other day it was a
beautiful day and um yeah I tried to do
about three hours of sport a day which
um is something I know I can see you
looking at me go what
um when I was locked up from covet and
we weren't allowed to even leave the
apartment for seven weeks that was like
hell and then when we first got out to
be able to do sport we could do two
hours of sport a day and it made me
realize that like the only person that's
stopping me from doing what I want to do
is me the government stopped me in those
times but then it's me that's stopping
me and I was constantly saying I didn't
want to do more sport I want to do more
sport but why wasn't I not doing it so
now I kind of say right I get up in the
morning I do my three hours of sport and
then I go to work in the afternoon and
because I work on America time it's it's
perfect I'm saying that because you know
I've won a lot of Awards as you can see
but I do not spend 12 hours a day in
front of the computer I enjoy my life I
love my job but I also love my personal
life as well and doing things for myself
so make sure you're all also taking time
out of your life do sport if you don't
like sport you know walk the dog what
are the plans do whatever it is you like
doing but don't do not sit in front of
the computer for 12 hours a day it's
really terrible for you okay
um enough about me we're here to talk
about testing simple question are you
writing tests
that is not bad that is good I know some
of you are like you I know I should be
doing more okay hands up who is not
writing tests at all
one person two people three people four
okay you're very honest that's great so
those of you are writing tests what are
you using are you using selenium
I don't even you can talk it's like it's
fine are you using selenium
no okay are you using Cyprus
interesting okay good any other testing
Frameworks
yes okay good
okay excellent
so there's a few of them okay brilliant
um
so let me just ask a few more questions
I want to get to know my audience
um JavaScript Developers
lovely.net Developers
okay we are half and half that's good so
I've made this talk to be 50 50. right
um Java developers
good I haven't covered you that's oh
there's one sorry you can take a seat
though
um okay on python developers okay lovely
I'm not covering you either but
um you can still watch this talk and go
home and do everything PHP Developers
good I think they're all dead that's
good
okay so let's continue uh testing
so what is the problem with testing or
what we what I think the problem is that
we're testing and you can
um agree or disagree when we start to
test kind of like testing is hard right
it's really hard to get Junior
developers on board to get them testing
any other problem getting Junior
developers on board to testing
or is it easy all Junior developers are
testing
no
what else what is what makes testing
difficult to get started
anyone
it's boring I love that I'm going to
change your life
um it takes time to learn right and
people don't have time I'm running for
three hours a day why don't run I cycle
for three hours a day I'll run for an
hour and a half
um but yeah I we don't have time because
we have you know more important things
to be doing
it takes time to build we're running our
tests on CI it's like oh my gosh you
know so that's another pain time is
money the product manager is coming
along and saying I need it shipped now
just delete the test don't even bother
writing tests just we want this out in
production it'll work it'll be fine your
code is always great lovely
and we don't have a very good testing
culture right we're literally not used
to testing we we put testing as an
afterthought something we do after we've
finished everything if I have time now
I'll test right
what have we had testing as the start of
something as like part of the normal
day-to-day let me give you the example
of of Twitter right Twitter are doing
alt tags on the images if you're sending
a Tweet now you can click that little
button and add an ALT tag who of you are
actually putting out tags on your images
okay that's terrible we need more of you
doing that right this is really
important because it includes other
people now I started to do this and it's
like oh my God it's taken me now four
minutes to send a tweet instead of like
a couple of seconds but I'm making my
tweets more accessible now that I'm in
the habit of doing it I just always add
and I'll tag to all my images on my
tweets all right and you can go and
check my Twitter feeds sometimes maybe I
might slip you know we're not perfect
but getting into the habit of doing
something means that then it just
becomes normal right like brushing your
teeth in the morning you don't even
think about it it just happens
testing we need to fix that culture so
that testing just happens and it's not
an afterthought
so how do we do that how do we get more
Developers
to write tests do you have the answer
anyone make it fun I love that anyone
else
make it easy excellent anything else
make it save time yes we can all go
running excellent so that's what we're
here to do right and I'm going to show
you a playwright because that's what I
believe playwright does it makes it easy
it makes it fun and it makes you save
time so let's have a look
so playwright testing first of all uh
who has heard of playwright
not bad that's um about 40 excellent
um who is using playwright in production
five people hmm don't worry I'm working
on you I'm working on you
um okay so playwright is reliable
end-to-end testing for modern web
applications it works in any browser so
you can test on Safari which always has
problems
um and any browser any platform you can
also test iPhone you can emulate test
iPhones and pixel Etc one API
full isolation which means when you
write your test that test everything is
like isolated so the next test does not
need or can't get anything from the
other one it creates a whole new browser
context every time you're writing a test
so Network caching all that kind of
stuff everything is cleared cookies
State nothing gets carried forward okay
so that makes your tests less flaky
because that test if it breaks it has
nothing to do with any other test in
your whole application it's just that
one test whatever went wrong went wrong
in that test a very fast execution all
tests run in parallel and they run for
free in parallel we don't have to do
anything to make that happen it's just
out of the box
um an unpowerful tooling which I'm going
to talk about today and it's
multi-language which is very important
especially if you're working in a
company that has a lot of teams back in
developers front-end developers who are
using different languages and then they
just have to learn one framework and
then they can still use that language of
their choice to write their tests and
everyone's just learning one thing but
writing in the language of their choice
so we support Java JavaScript typescript
Python and C sharp so you can write your
tests in any of those languages so
you're all here today for that so the
Java and python people I will not show
you any Java and python code but
everything that I show you you can do in
Java and python as well and I will show
you JavaScript typescript and C sharp
today
so I'm going to show you a little bit on
the vs code anyone using vs code
excellent beautiful so this is my
favorite way to get started if you're
not using vs code that's totally fine
you can still start it's uh not too late
um but no you can use the terminal for
everything as well I just like showing
in my talk vs code extension because
it's very visual it's also a very easy
way to get started or to show someone
very quickly and get them introduced
into testing so with the vs code
extension you literally search for it
make sure you find the one that says
micro Microsoft with the Blue Tick
because there's a couple of other ones
and this is the verified one that we
basically keep control of
so once we've installed the extension
then we literally type install
playwright and open the command panel
and what this does is then say okay
which browsers do you want to install do
you want to install chromium Firefox and
webkit all of them or maybe just want
one for whatever reason that's your
choice
and also it asks you do you want to
GitHub actions workflow and this is like
really cool right because you know then
obviously I want to get up actions
workflow because once I select that it's
going to create that for me I'm just
going to push my code to the repo and
every time I basically create a pull
request or push it's going to just run
my tests I don't have to do any work I
was creating the documentation for this
I was like saying to the team but what
do they need to do to get it work and
they're like nothing I'm like no I need
to document this what are the steps and
they're like it just works I'm like how
could it be it just works it just works
so literally that's the documentation
literally you just upload it into the
repo and your tests will run on each
push or pull request so that's great
views and GitHub uh it's amazing
so if you're getting started with C
sharp then you have to do um this great
project.net new console
um CD into that folder and then the
other Microsoft playwright package.net
build and then you'll do that install to
install required browsers
um once you've installed you'll get
something like this uh when you're
installing with JavaScript you'll get
the GitHub folder there that I just
showed you
'll get an example test that we created
just so you can get tests running very
quickly there's also a test example
which is a to-do demo demo app and you
can go into that in your own time and
play around with that and see all those
tests and then you get the playwright
config which you very rarely have to
touch because everything just works but
if you do need to configure anything or
maybe you want to add mobile testing for
example then that's where you configure
that
um if you're in C sharp then basically
after your install you'll install end
unit on Microsoft playwright end unit
then you create a test file and
basically run the test so pretty easy
running tests um you can run all tests a
set of tests a single tests and tests as
I said run in parallel so they just
whatever test is ready so it's not like
in you know one test number and then
number two and number three they're all
running parallel and it's super fast
so I'm going to show you running the
example test that comes when you install
using the vs code extension and you can
see I just pressed that little green
button of play and buying up comes the
browser window right you missed it I
know sorry I'll do it again okay so here
we go we're playing and it was just a
very simple test it was very there's not
a lot to see and that's the basically
example test so if you want to just
install and show someone this is what
you're going to get and this is how
you're able to demo that to someone and
say this is this is a test running
um if you want to run the test in headed
mode in C sharp then you'll just have to
add this code which is basically putting
headless equals false and then the
slow-mo equals 100 and then you'll be
able to run that in
um in headless mode with.net test
so live debugging I love this feature in
vs code where you can actually live
debug so I mean we never have bugs right
but the one time that you might have a
bug you're able to fix very easily in vs
code
so again this is just the example test
that I have and I'm just going to walk
through it so the text equals get
started I'm just going to change to Star
and I'll run that test it's going to
break right and it says to me error
there's a strict mode violation and
basically playwright found three
possibilities of the word star and
didn't know which one to click so it's
like I don't know which one you wanted
so I can create a break point right here
in the code and then I can run in debug
mode once I do that in the browser
window it's going to select what
playwright was telling me these are the
three things that hubstar star star
appears in all of these words star
appears and getting started it appears
and gets started and appears in the word
star
so then I can play around with this and
I can literally say all right instead of
star let's put started and it's going to
say oh there's two started there's get
started and there's getting started in
the footer so this is um not going to
work either
and I can play around with this look I
write the word playwright and there's
like 12 of these right so this is uh
showing me how many possibilities there
are of these selectors so get started
we'll fix that test but as you can see I
can play around and see it run the test
step through it and now the test will
pass because I have the right selector
to run tests in C sharp in debug mode
you'll use the PW debug equals one.net
run
and this is one I actually did
um in in.net
um
where it's it what it opens up is a
little bit different right so it's going
to open up the inspector so it's a
little bit different to what I showed
you in vs code also if you're using the
terminal this is what you'll get you'll
get this inspector window and you're
able to run through the tests like this
and you can see as we go through each
one so this uh this test broke
um on the listen later
um listen together sorry and listen
together text so as I step through one
by one I didn't create a breakpoint on
this I was just stepping through and you
know seeing it happen
and you'll see down at the bottom that's
the log that's happening and you can see
the Explorer there where the text equals
listen together
so as I was debugging this I'm like okay
this listen together is not here what's
going on and you can play around and say
right okay text equals room code I can
see that that one shows up I can see
that in my um in my window but listen
together I it's kind of like coming up
in the corner but it's not on the page
um there is one down at the bottom but
it's together it's not listened together
so you can kind of see what selectors
are available to as you're as you're
clicking along here
and then I can see down here the error
it's giving me it's waiting for the
selector text equal to listen together
the selector resolves to Hidden H1 tab
index equals -1 attempting to click the
action it's waiting for the element to
be visible enabled and stable but the
element is not visible so it's waiting
and then playwright said I don't know
where this is because it's just not
there
um so this is a way of kind of like
figuring out you know where is that
selector I can't see it on the page so
if I can't see it on the page playwright
can't see it on page and then playwright
can't click it
so um that's a way of kind of you know
testing that your selectors are there
and on debugging uh using the terminal
or using uh c-sharp as well
so locators what are locators you just
seen a couple of locators there on the
code locators are a way to find elements
on the page at any moment with built in
Auto waiting and retryability that means
playwright will wait for that to be
ready it's not just going to click it
it's going to wait until it's ready on
the page to be clicked and then if it's
not working whatever it'll retry
automatically and we'll try again
um after a certain time so you don't
need to set timeouts unless your code is
really bad and your JavaScript takes so
long to load it's going to take 10
seconds and then you need to do that and
they're nodding because they're like
I've written that code right yeah so
write better code so because playwright
is fast I think it's three seconds is
the default but you can change the
default in the config if you wanted to
um but yeah basically write better code
because playwright will wait for it to
be ready unless it's like way too long
and it's like this this app is terrible
right
um locators are written like this so you
could say cons to get started equals
page dot locator text equals get started
so the locator and then you've got the
selector I'm using a text selector here
uh you could use a CSS selector you
could use a role selector you could use
XPath stuff if you really want to
um so there's a lot of options there you
can put IDs test IDs in there so you can
choose which one you want and basically
choose the best selectors right the text
that button shouldn't that text
shouldn't change and that's what the
user will see right if you're using CSS
classes maybe it makes sense to use them
sometimes it does sometimes it doesn't
if you're using Tailwind for example
then you're going to have a real hard
time putting all those classes in so
maybe that's a good idea then to create
a test ID and use the test ID instead
so uh the same with um in.net you'll
have the say this is a page locator with
a header and inside the header is a
navigation and I'm expecting it to have
this array of features featured podcasts
available on powerdon.net so it requires
those given selectors and it waits until
it has all four elements with the given
text
web first assertions there are a lot of
assertions so you can go through to be
checked to be disabled to be editable to
be empty enabled focused to have class
to have count to have ID to have Js
property to have screenshot etc etc
very similar as you can see if you're
working in c-sharp pretty much the same
just sometimes it's capitalized and then
you just have async in the end so to be
checked async to be disabled async to be
enabled async to have value async etc
etc so make sure using assertions really
really important because this is what
it's going to create that await for you
and do everything as it should do
okay now I'm going to introduce you to
my best friend are you ready
me coach Jen
kojon will generate your tests by
recording your actions right you said
you want tests to be fun and you want
tests to be easy and you want to save
time this is code Jen
um now did you go to the GitHub co-pilot
uh talk earlier anyone yeah so this is
kind of similar-ish color pilot is
amazing I think it's great Cogen is
great um obviously it's Ai and we need
to make it better well it's kind of AI
but it's uh we need to make it better we
will make it better but I like it for
getting started I think it's really easy
so let me show you how it works so again
this is using the vs code extension and
I'm literally going to click that button
there that says record new this is in
the testing sidebar so when you first
install uh playwright you have the
little kind of sidebar uh testing icon
it probably is hard to figure out that's
a test testing icon but it is and when
you click there you'll get this testing
sidebar and then you'll have that show
browser which we see in to open the
browser we've got pick selector to pick
a selector and then we've got record new
so we're going to click the record new
so once I click record new I get a
browser window but also in vs code I get
a test dash one spec file already
created for me so now this is created in
my project
so I'll go to a website I'm going to go
to the NDC website and you'll see that
code was just written await page go to
NDC Oslo so let's you know accept those
cookies all good we love cookies
um so that's accepted it's written that
page text I'll go to click I'm going to
click on the heading here now the user
wouldn't normally click on the header
but I just want to record that because
I'm going to change it later
and I'll go down have a look what's
going on this page what do I want to
test I mean join the NDC party yes I
want to go here so I'm going to learn
more this is the only thing I'm
interested in this conference so um I'll
click on the Tuesday event let's say
y'all might sign up for that one that
looks good and this will open up another
browser window and I can test across
multi-domains because this as you can
see is a different domain I can see that
Community Tuesday and I'm gonna I have
no idea what that button says but I'm
sure it says sign up so I clicked it
um and then I'm like the Ford who's
going on this cruise on the Fjord Cruise
yes I'm going on this accent so I'm
going to see you there I signed up for
this as well
um so again I can check that that button
works and brings me to the page so I
went to another page and the NDC party
there's no sign of flex it's free but
the pub comes right so I'll sign up for
that and then I've gone to another page
the pub conf page and I'll click on that
um just on that text to make sure it's
there I could buy the tickets and
continue that testing and then I can go
back to the first one and I'll say right
I'm going to open this chat here and I'm
going to say to the conference
organizers that I basically really want
to come to the party so I'm going to
type this in here
I would love to come to the party
and I'm going to send this this is a
knife frame here as a shot I'm going to
send this oh and they're like Yay you
can come they're like no you have to
fill your name oh God here I go so I'll
fill out the name and then I kind of
went oh no you're not getting my email
so and there's my test done so literally
uh just by clicking around as a user
would normally do I have now got all
this code generated for me right that's
just super cool
this is a test literally as it is right
and you can see all those everything
that I have clicked through you can see
page one was so page is actually the
first page and page one is actually the
second page if you think of it that way
um so every domain there is a different
page and you can like go back between
those pages and you can test across
those multiple domains so if you have
those payment procedure stuff on
different domains then you can test your
application throughout those without any
any extra work you can test iframes
without any extra work just works as you
as you just just seen there so it just
uses the frame locator iframe and it'll
check everything
so that's my test with very little work
and that's how I get to do three hours
sport a day see easy and I can run that
and you can see it's running and it's
going to go to those domains it's going
to check it it's super fast but it
checked everything on Happy Days right
it's cool right
yeah are you convinced now
yeah kind of kind of uh all right so
um this is
um
yeah let me show you this because when I
actually run this it didn't really work
the test broke because sometimes
you know it's just clicking around and
sometimes it will work and then you go
oh but sometimes it doesn't work fully
and sometimes you got to like adopt your
your code a little bit and improve your
code right because yes we didn't do any
work let's make it better so what
happened here was um it kind of like
looked for that iframe and the locator
was text area and I was clicking on it
and I was like no this this uh this is
not working this is wrong so I'm like
okay
what what did I do what went wrong so we
can have a look in here
so we know it's the iframe the iframe is
the um that Chat thing and we can go
along and we can check on the first page
what what we need to select so what is
actually what we need to do so you can
pick the selector and we can say right
the selector as I'm clicking along here
the SVG now we don't want that and we
can say oh look there's a there's a div
there with a ID so that's kind of the
one I really want that's a better select
and I can click on that once I click on
that it's going to save it in this pick
selector box and then I can just press
enter and I now have it and I can paste
it in here and now I have a better
selector for my chat and this is now
going to work
so as I went through as yeah I'll run
this and you'll see that it works
[Music]
um
so sometimes as I said sometimes you
might have to go over your code and just
check a couple of things now if I go
back the test works right it's all
greens that's great did it actually work
do I really know let's go to the first
page and see my name Debbie's on that
page right so that did work so I fixed
my little selector problem
and now there's a couple of things I can
do to improve this right because the
code gen does not do assertions for me
it's just doing clicks and you saw I
clicked on the heading and a user would
not click on that heading but I did that
because I'm just lazy I wanted to save
time because now I can transfer that
from a click to a assertion and actually
this one is not a is a click so that
should stay the text is all good so that
should stay but this one has text okay
NDC Oslo that's the H1 and that one is
an assertion we wouldn't be clicking
that so we want to say expect that
locator uh two and you can see
everything that we can have to be
checked to be close to to be defined to
be disabled to be empty to be enabled
etc etc and we go down until we find the
one that we want and I just want it to
be basically visible on the page so I
can select that I want the H1 to always
be visible
and then I can go along and say okay
what else so learn more we clicked on
that that's good we expect the page to
have URL that's good uh the next page we
wanted to um to have that event to pop
up onto the next domain and sign up yeah
we want to do that
but the same H1 right the H1 has the
text of community Tuesday that's an
assertion let's change that from a click
to be an assertion so
um we want that to be visible on the
page every time we go there
and then we can go along to the next one
on the next one is that start uh I
cannot say this pamelitigan
so um yeah we want to make sure that's
clicked that's cool again another H1
um that shouldn't be a click event that
should be an assertion so let's go and
expect that one and we can go and add
more on this right I'm just doing a
basic example here but you might want to
also check that the image is there the
image has the L tag on the page
um that the button has an area label you
can do all that testing as well right
but this is just a simple way of taking
your code generated and literally going
through it step by step and just
improving it and adding those assertions
in
um so here we've got an um an image with
the alt equals Pub conf because that was
actually an image it wasn't
um a text but it has an out tag so
that's perfect so we just want it to be
to be visible
um it's already testing it has the Altex
that's great
and then we have our iframe that we
fixed and we put the right locator in
there so that's going to work and we're
also checking that we typed in we put
caps log and you can see what I filled
in I used the fill and I got I would
love to come to the party so that that's
good and then we clicked on the button
um it only found one button in that
frame so that was in that iframe so that
works perfect and then we've got a
locator of placeholder equals name and
we want to fill it with Debbie um
there's my test right again we could
continue on and then press that and see
what happens I would I don't know if
they email me back we could test that
but that's our test done we can rerun
that test as we've finished changing it
to assertions and Visually see does that
test still run and I can go back to that
first one and my name Debbie's is in
there so that test works I can go home
happy and everyone is going to get paid
and yeah have more free time on a Friday
so if you want to use code gen in
c-sharp then you'll basically use this
code here to run it or if you're using
the terminal as well and it's a little
bit different than in vs code and using
the terminal or using c-sharp but the
same two windows will pop up instead
right instead of having vs code you'll
have two windows the browser window and
this inspector window and from here you
can just go to the website I'm going to
test a different website this time I'll
test the uh the net podcasts website so
I put that in and you can see my c-sharp
code there it's a waiting page go to
async await the page locator has text so
again it's doing the same thing just in
C sharp instead of in JavaScript and as
I click around this site it's going to
basically start recording
all the actions I do so let's take a
um let's open this one here this podcast
we'll click on this one
for example we can see like as I was
testing this some of the images were
broken so I was like oh look I found
this problem like
um I don't know if they fixed it but uh
you can check but yeah as I was actually
just writing this test for this talk I
was like Wow look there's an issue here
there's a problem here I've come across
without even writing the test
um it'll test the image else is there so
that's good it has an L tag
so as you can see as I'm running through
this I'm for the first time I'm actually
kind of seeing if there's any kind of
issues and then I'm creating that test
and I'm able to then like go along here
inspect it find out what went wrong in
this this was a case where they had the
image Out Tag was coming from the back
end it was the same as the image name
and then if you had like you know a
little Gap in between it or something
then it didn't work so simple things to
to fix
so that's the tests uh running in Cogen
do you like my friend code gen
yeah it's kind of cool isn't it yeah we
give Coach and a club I love it I think
it's great we're gonna try and put uh
web first assertions into code gen it's
it's in the works so it's not going to
be there yet but in look forward to that
because I want to be able to like you
know click on that header and it knows
that you know actually you're not going
to ever click there that's not a click
event let's make that insertion and
expect it to be visible
um that's my hope it's going to happen
just takes time but for now it's a
pretty good start to get things going
so let me show you some reports right
this does only work
um for JavaScript typescript so this is
um the show reports it's a HTML reporter
we don't have it for c-sharp yet but a
lot of people have asked for it so we
may have it so just watch that space
um npx playwright show report this is
something you cannot do in vs code
extension you need to use a terminal so
we've got all the way up to Here Without
ever even opening a terminal which is
pretty cool but now if you want to
report you need to do this
so when I do this I'll get um basically
report and let me show you basically as
I write the command
uh the difference now is that it's
actually going to run all the tests on
all browsers so vs code not only just
runs it on one because it makes it
quicker when you're basically just
writing your tests but once you run it
with the terminal it's going to run on
all three browsers and it's running the
two tests I have that example test and
the test I created
um and that's why you're seeing six past
right so it's really par really fast to
run six two tests on three different
browsers so six pass very quickly and
then I'll just show the report
so the report opens up here on a
127.0.01 and I can just like click it uh
or I copy it over into my browser window
and here is my report
so the report will tell me everything
that happened in my test and you can see
um it goes through step by step so I
could Click on each one I can see which
tests have passed how many flaky tests
how many fails tests on which browser
was run on how long it took and
basically like you know see at all times
what's going on
now the trace files we can do what
npxplaywright test dash dash trace on
this is if you want to run it just
locally because you just want to see the
trace files
um I'm going to show you what the trace
files are so bear with me if you have no
idea what I'm talking about
um but the trace files normally would be
run on CI CD and it would normally run
um on the first retry so if on
continuous integration your test fails
it'll go oh something happened there let
me run that again and then it will
record that trace and then it will run
it again and then you'll have that trace
on that retry and you'll be able to go
through it debug it and see what happens
if you're using C sharp then you'll just
have to add this code in here to
basically get it to run so you'll say
screenshots true snapshots true source
is true and have the path traced.zip set
that up and then basically uh you can
drag and drop it onto the trace website
and then you'll be able to see the
playwright Trace it's a like a pwa so
it's local it's not like nobody can see
it unless you host it yourself but it's
basically a local pwa but you can send
that zip file to anyone and they can
basically open it and see it I'm going
to show you back to the JavaScript
version because this is what you get
when you do it locally with npx and
you'll get I don't know if you can see
it there but there's a little kind of
like um icon with two bars and it's like
it's a terrible icon because it doesn't
like tell me that that's a trace but
that's the icon for the trace and if you
click on that we'll open the trace so
let me show you
um so there's a like on here I can click
on or I can actually just go into the
actual test itself and I'll see a nicer
image that's easier to click so I'm
going to go to the test that we created
with code gen because I want to see this
one because it's more fun than the
example so this is the trace viewer and
what I can see here is I can go along a
timeline and I can see absolutely
everything that happened in my test at
every single point in time for every
event that locator text equals all good
that the click one the H1 there this is
my click event you can see the different
colors change depending on if it's a
click or if it navigated
and I can see the whole screen the
website of what's happening there and I
can basically just hover over here this
is waiting for an event then it has text
equals Community Tuesday
um as I go along here it's what was the
next one it was the frame was received
on the new page
um and you can see now I have a new page
underneath right so I can basically just
scroll down on the timeline and I can
see that other page and go back to the
first page
um I can go back and select the next
event we went down to the
um the Fjord cruise I can go down to
that page see what's happening at that
time and then we have the pump Pub
conference I can go down to that page
and see what happened there
um and basically see at all time over
those multi-domains I can see a whole
thing of what happened throughout the
test in my own time
scrolling along as slow and as fast as I
want to go but I can also go along here
and click on every single action so I
can stop and say right what happened
here I can see what's happening on the
page I can see everything is loaded so
here the text equals all good you can
see that red dot where it was clicked
that's the action what happened before
that and what happened after so the
cookie box went away when I clicked on
it so I can actually see that that's
exactly what should have happened this
is great
and again I can click through every
single action and you can see that it's
moving right it's scrolling there right
so it's not an image okay this is not an
image that you're seeing this is an
actual Dom snapshot you're seeing so
something to take into account
um you can see like the animations
happening there right it's it's a full
on Dom snapshot and yeah I can click
through all this action before after
what happened this is great for
debugging so if you have any errors you
can go to this you can really understand
everything that happened in that test
and why it wasn't working
so again going through here
um you can see the call on the other
side the locator.press the locator.fill
located on click
you can see the time you can see uh this
is like here's my um pop-up box came up
and you can go over here there's the
value Debbie that was added in so it
gives me all this detail the selector
was the iframe
um and before and after what happened
so you can see my name came up there and
after but before my name wasn't there
and I can actually type in it right
because it's a dumb snapshot it's
actually editable so I can literally
type in here all right which is kind of
cool I just think that's cool
um yeah so it's fun and then you've got
the console so I had any console errors
I could see them all in here
um here's like there's an arrow here so
I can see right there was something went
wrong so um they should fix that uh then
there's a network request I can see the
network requests that have happened so
it's like two aborted images or
something going on there so again I
could report that to them and I can see
the source code of the test so even
though I don't I didn't write that test
I can see the actual source code and
actually then send it to the developer
and say hey look you missed this I see
the error and you can see it was run on
chromium and is mobile false this looks
a bit bad because I just zoomed in so
much for the talk but normally it looks
much better but you can see exactly how
that's run so that's the trace viewer
it's really really amazing for debugging
and really really helps
um now if you want to configure tests
for mobile Safari which is basically
really easy
um
this is um did I do the right one I'm
recording the video here
and
no this looks like the wrong video damn
so yeah if you're going to configure
them for mobile basically what you do is
you go into the config I record a new
test that's it because the test on
mobile just passed and I want to show
you something different it's going to
record a new test that just clicks the
menu right so this is a new test it's
just going to basically test the menu I
play that I run it and this works it's
perfect
okay very simple test just testing
functionality uh now if I want to test
this on mobile right I want to make sure
because you know menu navigations are
mobile it's always a disaster so I can
go into
um the playwright config file so here
you can see down here and it's already
like there so I can just literally
scroll down and you can see it's comment
commented out by default so I've got the
mobile Safari and I'm just going to test
on Mobile Sapphire and I could also test
on mobile Chrome on edge on devices
pixel 5 on everything right but let's
just do mobile Safari
and then when I run this test because
I'm using the vs code extension it's
going to take this one it's going to run
that one I could configure it to
basically only run
um the only run that to run all of them
if I go in and configure that but I just
want to run this one
um when I'm in terminal and now you run
test it's going to run every single test
so just keep that in mind if you're
using the extension it's going to run
just that last one you did and use the
terminal if you want to see every single
test and get that report so I want to
see the report and you can see there
that test has failed right so I've got a
problem uh with my test actually two of
them have failed so the first one fails
and the second one failed so let's go
and inspect why that failed and see how
we can improve that so it said like
strict mode violation on the iframe that
was the first one we looked at earlier
so I could go and debug that or I can go
in here and see this one failed which is
um has tickets has text tickets cannot
be found right so this fails on mobile
and we'll have a look and you will see
like this like once it fails it stops
the trace right it couldn't go any
further so record it up to the point uh
said like I have no idea I can't
continue I'm broken uh you need to fix
me and it's like on this text here right
has text tickets uh is not there the
select a result hidden uh it's
attempting to click the action and
I can inspect this right because this is
a Dom snapshot so it gives me all the
access to Chrome developer tools just
like any website so now I can go along
here and I can start understanding
what's going on in my website and I can
kind of see right well I get this right
because it has tickets is not there
because my mobile menu is obviously
different to my you know other menu so
it's not there it's hidden behind this
hamburger menu okay and I didn't tell
playwright to click that hamburger menu
so it's basically not going to find it
and I can you know search true and kind
of understand the code because maybe I
didn't write that code as I'm writing
that test I'm kind of saying yeah okay
so that that tickets are there it's just
it's stuck under a nav menu right so I
can now go along and fix that test write
a better test that includes that
any idea how you would fix this test how
you would actually make the test work
for the mobile menu anyone
no ideas
check for what kind of menu you have I
like that's good anyone else
no dude
very easy we can use is mobile so you
can basically pass in the is mobile
fixture and say you know if it's a
mobile I want you to await the page
locator navigation menu because you need
to click that menu and then you can go
and do the has text workshops or has
text agenda or whatever but you need to
click that menu each time so when I'm
writing this test now I need to
basically go back and every time I need
to put if is mobile you need to click on
the hamburger menu because that's how
the mobile functionality works the menu
never stays open like on the desktop so
I've got to like tell playwright if
you're on a mobile click the hamburger
menu then go and click that if you're on
a mobile click this if you're on a
mobile click this or we can say if
you're not a mobile uh do Etc right so
you can use whatever and then when I run
that test you can see it clicked it and
it opened it up and clicked it and
opened up clicked it open it up and my
test works right so that's an easy way
of making sure things work and testing
across uh mobile and across desktop
um very quickly I'll show you another
simple example there in C sharp when I
was running the.net podcast one and we
found an error with the um you saw it
earlier in the video with the listen
together text right and as I was
searching along here and I'm like I did
not understand what was going on and I
started using the developer tools to
kind of figure out what was happening in
this scenario so this is like I said
it's a really great way of debugging but
also understanding the code and in this
one it's like okay listen together the
text is not there I went through
everything I was like why are you not
there like what is going on and I can
see it's actually here right the text is
in the H1 class is there so I've got a
H1 the test is broken because looking
for the H1 and the hatred's not there on
mobile it is not there on desktop it is
you can see it in devtools and I found a
display
non-dammit what developer decided to on
mobile put a display none on the H1
heading so I tried to understand what
did this developer do why would they do
that and how can I fix this so um yeah
if you if I went I went to the actual
desktop version and I could see that
listen together text that H1 is there
and I'm like okay so it's there and then
you've got like that other thing
underneath it but if you look at the um
when I put display none on
um that text is there but a H1 is at the
bottom of the page right in the middle
of the page that's not the right order
so this developer basically decided okay
Flex is too difficult and this is
putting it down the bottom of page
doesn't look good so let's just remove
it from the page yay solve the problem I
go home and then playwright went yeah
this is not good okay so it's a great
way of finding your problems that your
developers have you know put into
production and gotten away with
um so keep that in mind so you can run
your tests on CI Wicket of actions we
talked about that earlier this is
basically the um uh the actions uh that
it's created so this is done for you you
don't need to do anything
um with this unless you're doing
component testing if you're doing
component testing there's another like
another run that you'll put in there
with the component testing and you'll
add that to it will run your end-to-end
test and then your component tests
um and then you get something like this
on on CI and your actions and you'll
have your failed ones your past ones and
you'll be able to go in those and check
your workflows and go down and you'll
see there on that failed test I've got
that playwright report I can then click
into that report and I've got that Trace
file I can download that Trace file I
can use I need to use the playwright
server to actually serve it up so just
keep that in mind and then I'll run that
and figure out what went wrong or send
it to the developer and say fix this
this broke
um so yeah component testing anyone
writing components in view
yeah a couple of you not too many react
our lovely sveld
nobody angular
yeah a few years okay sorry we don't
have angular support
um so yeah component testing maybe we
will do one day but component testing is
um is run using Veet so uh this is why
we don't have angular because it's it's
Veet is not supported by angular
um yet so if you were doing component
testing you need to install this npm
internet playwright at latest CT CT for
component testing and this will get
basically allow you to write components
and test components now very simply
um you can basically just create your
components and run them I'm going to
test
um the message prop there I'll run that
and you can see that this kind of comes
up in the browser so I can visually see
my components rendering on the page I
can remove that prop and then I can run
that test and I can also visually see
that that prop removed there's nothing
there the test broke
um it tried it was like where is this
where is this prop and it kind of said
hey I expected we didn't play playwright
and I got nothing so you know what do
you want me to do here
so I can add that back in that test will
work and I can go through each component
uh one by one and basically like just
press the play button open the code this
is a testing a slot for example in view
test that the count is included in the
vslot count and this will come up and
there it's beautiful it's included there
and then I can test that the count
component actually counts so this one
should be clicked every time it clicks
it goes up one and buying that count is
two is so fast that you missed it I know
um you can slow it down if you want to
but basically this is a great way
creating components and then writing
some simple tests alongside it it
doesn't take long to do that
um so I suggest you do test your
components
um so then we've got the vs code
extension so playwright testing right
you've got your vs code extension which
I showed you you've got code gen to Auto
generate your tests right you've seen
that you can run in debug mode you've
got locators and frame locators right so
you can test across iframes you saw the
show reports uh you you saw how to view
Trace files and debug your applications
Auto weight is built in for all actions
right so there's no need uh to set
timeout calls tests run in parallel for
free uh it's super fast multiple
browsers and multiple devices we saw
that and it's also got intercepting
requests follows all redirects bypasses
cores and manages cookies so that's kind
of cool
and basically I I just have really kind
of one question for you are you ready to
play right have I convinced you
yeah seriously yeah just tell me yes
this is cool or no you can be honest are
you ready to play right
I love that that's amazing so um my name
is Debbie O'Brien as I said uh my email
is Debbie Brian microsoft.com I never
really read emails but if you want to
send me an email you can
um the dogs are playwright.dev
um we've got a Twitter account YouTube
we will have more video content coming
there is a community slack channel so if
you do have any like problems you know
just yeah put them in the slack channel
uh playwright is open source it's
completely open source and free
um It Is by Microsoft so
um we just have a lot of support and we
can do a lot of stuff but it's a
Community Driven project so if you have
a feature request something you want to
maybe you want angular support right
then you create that feature request if
that gets upvoted we do it everything
runs through GitHub everything is in the
open you can visually see everything
um and it's getting better and better
each time so I want something like the
watch mode for components so as you're
building your test it watches and then
we'll just kind of rebuild that instead
of pressing play because that extra
second I just don't want to do right so
that's kind of other stuff that we will
work on component testing is
experimental so you know play around
with it and let us know your feedback in
general
um I would love to hear your thoughts on
playwright if you're using it in a
company and have a lot of tests and
we're building a case study page so come
and talk to me I will be on that Fjord
Cruise because I booked my ticket so I
will be there tonight if anyone wants to
talk about playwright on the cruise
please come up to me uh I know it's the
end of the day you're welcome to stay
back and ask questions you're welcome to
ask questions here we've got a couple of
minutes before we should finish
um but I will also be here all day
tomorrow I'm not here Friday but feel
free to come and reach me if not on
Twitter Deb's underscore O'Brien uh
thank you very much for your time and if
you have any questions just put your
hand up thank you
I know everyone's like beer I just want
beer what time is beer right
um any questions yes
yes there is Shadow Dom support
yes
look in the selectors documentation I
think it's in a selectors or location
documentation just search Shadow Dom but
it's there yes
yes
uh yeah you can use the the viewport
size so you can change the the viewport
you can just use test use and then put
in whatever viewport you want
sorry
I think there is I again I'm using more
I'm just showing more GitHub but there's
a lot of we're implementing a lot of
azure stuff um but don't quote me on
everything Azure because I don't do a
lot of azure work but yes there is um
there is support on azure
and it's in the Azure static web apps
template by default now
yes
to intercept the websocket communication
you want me to answer that right now
okay
um yeah now check check the
documentation there's some documentation
on websockets I haven't played around
with that
um if that documentation isn't good
enough
chat us on slack and we'll we'll improve
that or find out a way but I haven't
haven't tested myself a good question
thanks
anyone else yes down here
the application
so authentications authentication yeah
so there's a great documentation on
authentication
um that you can check out with some
examples obviously authentication is
hard right because it depends on what
you're authenticating uh if it's like
you know a two-factor and needs a mobile
phone to test that so I don't have all
the answers on authentication
um but definitely reach out to us
intelligent use case and what you're
trying to do and we can try and point
you in the right direction
thanks
anyone else
going once
oh over here I can't see this big light
oh he's standing up sorry yes all the
way over there
and it's testing like end-to-end and you
change one thing
how much work is it to change all the
tests
what do you want to change what are we
talking about
okay say you have a login that you're
testing and that's something you got to
do in all of your tests because you got
to be authorized okay and you change
something in the login things that
breaks all your tests what do you do so
you shouldn't have any tests that
depends on another test
right so all your tests should run
independent and if you have something
like a login you can use it before each
hook so before each is going to log in
so you you could have all those tests on
one page if you don't have them on the
one page if you have them separate you
can use fixtures or page object model
um and then you just have that one test
um that basically is is doing that so
you're gonna have to fix it only in one
place
a good question
anyone else yes
um not so much I don't think we
recommend it uh as a.net developer I
don't really can't go into wise on that
but um but yeah
um end unit is is the way forward but
maybe we might have in the future X unit
but by the moment we don't have that
support
anyone else
going once
going twice
yes it is beer time thank you very much
I hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference I'm around all day tomorrow
thank you for your time